novas famílias nós você
tecnologias no fundo isto trás
aquela idéia de que vivemos em crise de
valores e levando sempre uma história
que minha mãe me contava sobre a avó
dela portanto minha bisavó que morava em
lisboa na avenida da liberdade e que ia
para a janela tinha muita vergonha
porque eu ia pra geral insultar os
primeiros que passavam com as costas à
mostra por que o facto e as chamadas
avermelhadas e coisas do gênero disse
prevemos que não são de crise de valores
de mudança e de alguma maneira a
tecnologia ou seja o que for e ao
triângulo de uma forma negativa é que o
que são as nossas vidas é naturalmente
uma coisa que nos acompanha sempre sofre
internacionais é concentravam sempre
funcionando eu acho triste quadro é um
tributo o gosto se conhecem mas o jardim
das delícias e vai sair assim no fundo
naquilo que é uma dicotomia não é o céu
eo inferno temos um purgatório maio e
isso foi uma das coisas que tem mudar de
fato nossa lei nós hoje em dia cada vez
menos vivemos em economias
na verdade está um perigo como o o o
crescimento da criança eu acho que é um
perigo nesse sentido nunca mais tem
desenvolvido
nós ensinamos às nossas crianças o que
está certo eo que está errado o que é
bom eo que é mau é essa história das
crianças têm sempre um mau um bom
não é porque é que o que nós queremos
ensinar é distinguir entre o preto eo
branco ou mal é verdade que cheiro é
depois encontramos os cinzentos e
pessoas que a vida não é preta não é
branca não é bom não é mar é
naturalmente pautada por diferentes tons
e cada vez mais nesta altura o nosso
mundo tem se envolvido nesse sentido na
perspectiva z é em vez de sermos a
energia irmos já com tudo terminado como
acontecia antes precisamos que antes nós
vimos país sociais que estavam
deslocadas unidos o filho do padre iria
ser parâmetro já sabe a pessoa com quem
se ia pesar e portanto a nossa vida
estava de terminar a partida
hoje em dia cada vez mais do que nós
vamos viver numa sociedade onde as
pessoas possam escolher a partida já
dizemos que o melhor para os nossos
filhos e daquilo que os quiserem ser e
portanto nesta perspectiva vamos
percebendo que nossa senhora foi mudando
de algo que se centra em algo que é
muito mais pré determinado
aquilo que era o vai fazer o mal fazer
vamos vivendo numa sociedade onde é que
o que é bom é que o pessoal queria para
si próprio e portanto vamos claramente
velocidade escolhas numa cena as
diferenças e branco é isso que no fundo
tem acontecido também em 2010 elas
continuam a ser tão importante como
sempre foram uma família representa é
aquilo que a nossa segurança nós pontos
base
não é nossa mas agora o modelo de
família
naturalmente tem se vindo a alterar em
função daquilo que também são as
diferenças entre as pessoas
se ele vir antes que antes a família uma
família tradicional pai mãe e filhos
hoje temos família mesma pessoa temos
menos de dois anos nós temos femininas
duas mulheres também sumiu e um dos mais
inventivos porque naturalmente as
pessoas vão vivendo essas diferenças e
portanto não podemos falar em uma crise
familiar
falando assim naturalmente famílias
diferentes
depois há quem pergunte são então os
valores que estão em crise atual são as
famílias não serão os valores que estão
em crise
os jogos também mudaram e mudar um pouco
o mundo inventimentos também um vôo
tudo é diferente hoje em dia eu vim do
porto por aí
duas horas e meia no passado fazer uma
viagem do porto para lisboa era uma
coisa num dia e muitas vezes não vos vou
fazer uma reunião de duas horas no
passado em ser impensável o mundo hoje é
muito mais fluido é nossa tempo virá
como civis é muito mais curta um espaço
é muito diferente nós no passado
tínhamos se calhar na vida o potencial
de crescimento de cerca de 500 pessoas
hoje podemos conhecer 500 pessoas num
dia evidentemente que o nível de
relacionamento que vamos desenvolver com
as pessoas têm que ser diferente é se
antes tínhamos tempo
relações muito profundas e
essencialmente excluía hoje e não temos
tempo pra essa profundidade emocional
independentemente de ela existir na
algumas nossas emoções nós vivemos muito
mais a imagem como e vibrante
se eu vou conhecer 500 pessoas não lia
tem que apresentar de uma forma que
transmita é que o que eu quero
transmitir que não vou ter outra
oportunidade e estenda ao normal e
natural e temos que perceber isso não
como um prêmio mas como uma realidade e
ao que traz naturalmente coisas muito
positivas mas que muda a forma como
valorizamos as coisas e portanto
naturalmente a imagem é hoje bem mais
importante do que no passado e isso é
natural não é algo que seja fútil não é
algo que seja negativo disse que serão
então se calhar as novas tecnologias que
estão dá uma flor por emprego a moldar o
mundo e modificá lo quando no fundo
pegar o que aconteceu que tem o
contrário
nessa tecnologia acompanham estas iraque
mundo foi perdendo se não fosse a
tecnologia nós não estávamos aqui juntos
e não tinha vindo do porto e não
conseguiríamos este nível de comunicação
das tecnologias existem no mundo e vão
acompanhando a evolução é naturalmente
para corresponder àquilo que as pessoas
procuram e não o contrário
não temos que naturalmente então ter
mesmo que isto nos modificar uma forma
negativa como se mudarmos fosse algo que
nos trouxesse negativo irá a nossa vida
deve então estão a afetar as boas só
eles o fato hoje em dia como é que é
possível os tímidas como é que é
possível todas aquelas formas de
relacionamento à distância está a
prejudicar as moções
elas naturalmente hoje em dia não podem
ser jamais estavas podemos estagnar já
não temos capacidade de lutar por uma
relação de fato isso é também mentira
direito das pessoas filhas relações
existem desta maneira
os programas dessa maneira porque as
pessoas procuram e procuram que vivem de
facto as relações de forma diferente
não vivemos as emoções da mesma maneira
como vemos a pouco a gente importante e
portanto a imagem vez desta forma o
casamento está em crise
eu diria que o pensamento esteja em
crise eu diria que de facto moveu o
casamento é que está em crise
já não vivemos relações internas a idéia
não é vivermos fluidos para sempre com a
mesma pessoa
este já é mais difícil nos escrever na
casa e porque evitava aumento qual era a
grande motivação do casamento no passado
estamos na questão da família vivemos
mochilar quando a mulher não tinha
contraceção evitar ao menos engravidava
muitas vezes tinham muitos filhos não
podia ter uma carreira não podia ter um
trabalho estava dependente do marido que
trabalhava então eu tinha que sustentar
essa melhoria dos filhos tanto é
fundamental praça miami e promover
organização familiar
de facto o casamento fosse estável
não se podia fazer e ter dez filhos e
depois naturalmente e vai ter outra
freguesia
hoje em dia não é necessário
hoje em dia a mulher se deu quando os
filhos quer ter quantos filhos não quer
se na altura em que ter os filhos ou da
escritora os filhos escolhe teor escolhe
não ter e portanto naturalmente
desenvolve estuda tem uma carreira
tornas autônoma e independente
já para conseguir sua vida então
naturalmente o casamento deixa de ser
fundamental como estabilidade
já não precisamos viver a vida toda
começou então qual é a motivação do
pensamento hoje dizemos ao humor
estamos apaixonados é evidente que vai
jantar pelo temos uma motivação
emocional pra algo que supostamente
criamos curasse toda a vida quando serão
esquecidos são fluidas mudam alteram
quando sabemos
nos apaixonamos temos tudo menos uma
perspectiva é fundamental regional da
vinda é também sempre dizer o amor é
cego
então se é cego como é que eu sei que
consigo encontrar possa durar uma
revolução a vida toda é muito mais
difícil então evidentemente essa
motivação é o amor é mais difícil que a
relação dura toda a vida
não quer dizer que seja impossível não
quer dizer que não possa acontecer mas
não é isso hoje em dia o suposto
casamento não é isso o gene um suposto
das pessoas se juntarem o pressuposto da
sua junta já estar em baixo está em um
fuso não era esse o suposto casamento
antiga grande e temos que ver isto e
aceitá lo com natural e da ásia que
também evidentemente o encontrarmos uma
solução e depois terminarmos essa rua
são naturalmente deixa de ser um drama
será que os torna mais influenza
eu não posso acreditar que a tecnologia
nos possa tornar mais influência
lembro de uma história que houve uma vez
um contato com o ministro são as áreas
em que na altura se ponderava colocar a
água canalizada em todo país na saldanha
sensual da resina
não vamos fazê lo porque se tivermos
água canalizada vamos privado aquela
senhora anos daqui um momento importante
na vida delas que é quando vão a fonte
secar água encontram as amigas e
portanto têm a oportunidade de conversar
não acreditamos nisso não vamos dizer
que essa tecnologia nos poderia tornar
mais influência porque é que esta
tecnologia nos poderia tornar mais
influência é evidente que traz
diferenças e é importante que nós
saibamos reconhecer essas diferenças
tivemos que por exemplo nas relações à
distância e não sabemos se elas duram
mais tempo menos tempo
extraímos outra vez aquela noção que uma
relação só é de sucesso segurar diretor
viram que nós acreditarmos nisso é só
sabemos que nossa relação foi de sucesso
quando morrer mos o que de facto uma
mostragem vantagem importante
não poderíamos avaliar o sucesso de uma
relação pela duração mas não há dados
que indiquem que as relações a distância
dure menos queijo uma forma tradicional
agora têm características diferentes é
mais difícil apaixonados a distância é
porque inevitavelmente não achando nuno
a top no olhar e é isso que nos faz
apaixonar 1 são as características das
pessoas que nos fazem apaixonar
isso é bom para termos relações
positivas mas nos apaixonamos pela
cicatriz que ninguém e emoções anuais de
fato tenha ser olha se quiserem mais
íntimas que as moções faça fácil porque
o que nós dizemos muito mais coisas
online do que dizemos faça fácil é mais
fácil falarmos de nós pessoas não
entendem harris mais e dizer mais coisas
sobre si próprias e reconhece a senhora
se sente
evidentemente não é isso que
necessariamente fazer uma melhor relação
é também precisamos por exemplo uma das
características e funções online é que
promove em vitaminas do conflito no
momento do conflito porque é só sonhar
né
se passar com a face a face com a arc a
estes podem entender ganhar tendência a
evitar mais esse conflito e desligar com
maior facilidade
temos que perceber isto e percebe se
facilmente essas foi a termos um pm
nestas coisas agora necessariamente não
podemos dizer que é um erro o real que é
muito especial às pessoas o que são
apenas as pessoas sozinhas que estão
nestas coisas é exigir ante as pessoas
que estão sozinhas porque correm mas
agora esse mal se não tivessem
tecnologia então se alastre ainda mais
sozinhas podemos dizer então são coisas
que evidentemente não tem que fazer
refletir e seguramente mais uma vez não
está seguramente nos seus romances não
está em crise
podemos dizer se calhar ia acreditar que
o romance que o amor internos que já
está em crise
o amor eterno hoje se calhar não existe
não quero trazer os mais notícias
futuramente por gravar daqui casais
apaixonados é naturalmente vão negar
isso que eu estou a dizer vamos ver não
senhor
o nosso amor é eterno é eu vos dizer
assim é ótimo que acredita nisso não tem
nenhum problema eu próprio também
acredito que o meu amor com minha mulher
é eterno
na época quando estamos apaixonados e
quando sentimos isso acreditamos nesse
perfeitamente todos vocês sabem que vou
morrer um dia
não é novo a pensar nesse momento se
sabe até que podem morrer aqui cinco
minutos vejam o nível de emprego que
sentiriam se acreditasse nisso
não é porque sabemos que é possível que
naturalmente pensamos nisso
o homem é um animal que sabe que vai
morrer num único mas vive sem o a morte
foi um movimento então nós podemos
perfeitamente saber e perceber e
compreender que é muito difícil pro amor
eterno exista não é por causa disso que
vamos deixar de acreditar nela
não é por causa disso que vamos deixar
nos apaixonar não é por causa disso que
vamos viver as relações sempre
exatamente como se fosse a última que
nós vamos ter que ser bom porque isso é
muito positivo que nos dá uma ótima
energia é portanto não temos que estar
preocupados com a ideia de que não tem
que ser mentira e se é verdade é por
causa da tecnologia portanto vai me
refugiar nisto ou fugir daquilo
é verdade que há algumas dimensões que
nós temos que conseguir considerar
quando pensamos nas funções online
quando pensamos no efeito da crise este
nível há coisas que envia também podem
acontecer a tecnologia traz muito
conforto
nunca mais me esqueço um amigo meu
uns anos é esta nova 300 ipad que já
começava a surgir é e eu mostrava o
tablet
e dizia o consigo estar a ver filmes
horas seguidas aqui a fazer não sei
quantas horas sozinho ou seja é tem
gerado uma sensação de satisfação muito
grande e ver a autonomia aí eu posso
estar sozinho horas e fim de uma
incrível não estou motivo não me sinto
sozinho talvez então eu ficar com uma
sensação de que de facto tudo estava em
que vivemos muitas vezes negociações
podem ser altamente perturbadores mas
que nós aguentamos e suportamos e
mantemos e diminuímos a nossa capacidade
até dias muda é porque nos sentimos dá
alguma forma satisfeitos e compensados
por essa tecnologia isto de facto tem
que nos fazer refletir um pouco porque
nos fazer perceber que não é o
diagnóstico ou pula
não podemos é que ir outra vez naquilo
que é o paradoxo é num paradoxo que não
estaria se vai ver depois tentarmos de
culto mizar o nosso estado não se
antevia avaliar nós estamos bem normal
que os sinais e exterior
temos muita gente que parece muito bem
que parece muito satisfeita
está muito bem mas mantém depois muitas
vezes as relações e questões muito
perturbadores na sua vida e diminui a
sua capacidade de trabalhar e aqui que
eu acho que é fundamental que façamos
por exemplo papel e puxando a brasa à
minha sardinha da psicologia no mundo e
na capacidade de ajudar as pessoas a
conhecerem melhor a este esforço que nós
temos que fazer não é um esforço de
combater ecologia não é um esforço
rejeitar experiência saques princesa wii
é um esforço nos aprendemos a conhecer
vai receber menos que facto somos
capazes de fazer as mudanças que
entendermos que possam ser mais de
acordo com aquilo que são as nossas
características porque é isso que o
nosso mundo mostrou 11 pessoas queda vez
mais diferentes entre si e é isso que
será nos traz razões é é a capacidade de
com
dessa vez mais pelo possa exprimir essas
diferenças na perspectiva de que se
assim for não é cada um possa atingir o
máximo da sua funcionalidade
esse portanto vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]